ce mardi la ville de Trappes organisait
une opération de recrutement dans le
secteur de l'animation objectif affiché
grossir les rangs d'animateurs pour
faire face à la réforme des rythmes
scolaires à la rentrée prochaine début
des classes une demi-heure plus tard
pose du Midi rallongé de 30 minutes et
fin des cours à 16h en tout une heure et
demie de ton périscolaire à comblé par
jour et forcément les postulants
perçoivent plutôt bien cette nouvelle
organisation a priori vu que tu auras
besoin de plus de personnel donc ça
offre plus d'emplois la ville de trappe
fait un gros plein aujourd'hui sur ce
projet je pensais novateur je trouve que
ça peut être porteur pour avoir une
ambition pour nos jeunes je pense à
beaucoup de jeunes ils aiment
l'animation je pense que ouais ça va
permettre à plusieurs viandes de
travailler etc les postulants ont donc
répondu en nombre ici on fignole CV et
lettre de motivation 25 postes
d'animateurs sont à pourvoir 10 à temps
complet
temps partiel et 8 postes de directeur
ou référents périscolaires dans le
couloir Florent animateur environnement
vient postuler avec son bac + 2
c'est les filières qui sont diplômantes
donc mais qui sont bouchés encore à
l'heure actuelle et au niveau de l'État
on fait beaucoup de publications en
disant il faut faire de l'animation
nature il faut sensibiliser au
développement durable et les postes ne
sont pas créés et pour les rares postes
accessibles c'est en bac +3 voir en
master donc ça devient très dur de
pouvoir participer à la protection de
l'environnement comme salarié et pendant
l'entretien il s'en sort plutôt bien on
attend de toi
on est preneur à la clé une embauche ou
en partenariat avec son association une
deuxième salle de recrutement pourrait
s'organiser à partir d'octobre prochain
pour s'adapter au nombre d'enfants
participants au temps périscolaire